previously on raft okay look guys
there's bees in here I don't trust these
bees I don't think that's where our boat
was either you're kind of the ex I'm
gonna run around in I'll chop some
little trees I saw a Bruns song one of
three relay stations are now active
Wade's making moves I'll be dead very
soon we're out in the water you came
back a horror monster what if you do
your solo normally I don't know man
no you're you're you're animation speed
is like doubled because your breathing
cycle is how much would you guys manage
to get well between having to restock
the things and I'd have to rebuild a
bunch of planks
we got net plus of 18 okay teens not
nothing it's not much mark we don't have
any planks in these grill the line rows
no the little girls are not sufficient
they're very inefficient maybe we should
get rid of those and just make another
large I don't think that's a good move I
think that's a smart play I think that's
fresh play okay I don't know what that I
am my health went down what are you
telling me a Robbie gives nothing I
think that's right much Oh
WeHo my god wait watching you is gonna
make me throw up
should we chug around and just try and
get resources then should we do nothing
laughs I think we have to we'll do
another lap and then we'll get enough
resources to go back on the island and
then we'll all have bottles water we
have 14 vine - I just made myself a
water bottle I'm actually did you put
the goo back in I only took out enough
to make it okay I'm gonna make one of
them up with the goo there's enough for
another water bottle if you want it to
come on make one for me I willed
hand-deliver one to you hell it up would
you I will make it fill it and I will
give it to you and your cup will be no
more you can abandon the cup I am gonna
Chuck my clothes right in the top to
refill the thing it's okay we have like
nine million plastic and it's like free
plastic I'm coming to give you a bottle
oh it's down there you can get it Oh
what what kind of half-assed service is
this it's all the ass I know you don't
need a cup you can you can you can fill
these bad boys you don't need a cup but
wait is a little mop see it Oh first off
I know that's why I went fast wait why
are you over there help with the shark I
don't feel very fast and Wade you can
fill one of these things with the
plastic bottle it's much better than a
cup so I don't even need the cup so what
all you need right now there's it just
would obviously would I think it's what
we're hurting for but we could also use
advanced stuff well that most of that
stuff's what we get under the water if
you mean like metals and things right
yeah but I
this quote-unquote island is gonna have
this stuff but I gotta feel like there's
there's some secret on this island
Wade was discovering things and turning
things on we got to do the rest of that
we just look for stations and there's
crates of stuff in the station's just
nothing for water like you've learned
the island Wade do you feel like you
could stock up and go back into the
islet and try all the signs literally
pointing in the directions then all I
did was follow the signs I think we
should get back and close drop weight
off and then leave him there is more
story on this island and I want to get
to it
well I'm just saying I want to keep
chugging the boat around okay I think
one farm that's one of us should maybe
grind food or two of us should go Island
yeah well yeah yeah yeah yeah I
definitely want two water bottles I'm
going back to the island though I don't
know why would you need two water
bottles you get a full bar of water if
you you could fill it up five jugs I
would have to come back to the boat I
couldn't do all four stations on one
bottle thank this guy this guy I'll run
out and I'll just grind I'll grind
cooking what we've got and I'll just run
the boat with planks and whatnot we've
got plenty of food god you're so greedy
I don't like the way you're anything I
laid down but I fixed me am i fixed nope
you're even faster I think I need to
make another spear or is a machete
better than spear I think a machete is
better okay that old spear was
definitely better than the wooden spear
for the Bears I imagine the machete is
even better I make a machete I made a
machete so I'm good on weapon apparently
killed that bird yeah I won laughs the
word the word the word I'm gonna put
more plants in these engines cuz you're
about to run okay if you fill your water
thing you then cannot refill the water
we might need another bottle for
refilling Thanks
well I hear I've got my cup still I've
not thrown out my cup
myself another cup we have like a
lifetime supply of plastic this
technically we could make some more vine
goo and make one more bottle only I
hadn't wasted vine goo on making this
stupid rebreather that did I don't have
anymore cuz I died with it God my
rebreather sound like your fault I'm not
really one but myself like we're blaming
people in that that's not very nice
slamming myself how could you easily I'm
an [ __ ] this is very pretty by the
way guy got admit the island looks
beautiful right now picturesque I know
what a great ass
weird that it's glowing and slightly
opaque like a ghost island that doesn't
really exist and that's going on is just
us absorbing the curse of it but very
pretty here comes a knife of barrels
there's another barrel off the right
side I'm too far away no you're not both
of you suck no no I would have had that
Bob thank you
coming down over there whoa that is a
place that you don't get it all right
Bob those on me I killed this York waved
it around watch there's a bird eating
your vegetables
no no not for long does a burden do okay
I missed I'm really regretting this tall
tall driving position now that I
volunteered to run the whole boat by
myself what fool you know what I'm just
gonna put L where it belongs up tepee
top II know I'm down here just just for
ease of manipulation wait you almost
ready you got food in your env2 E yeah
I'm good
all right 30 seconds God be with us that
was a Saving Private Ryan joke for
anyone who didn't know okay way to
inform me of what we are going to get
it's like the it's like the the big boat
that we had to find stuff at so what did
you find already I went up to the right
and then to the right from the bear okay
what
that if that helps it didn't but I'll
figure it out I'll be fine all right
Jesus Christ look you can see a on
twitch is real bad right now so I got to
do this version you know you guys know
okay let's go for six or go with me
either way I'll go four and six if I
need help
at least I won't be seeing you do you
want liquor there are no bears in these
woods I don't know what you're talking
about there you go got that hey the bear
that's eating the berries is that just
gonna be there forever
yeah so the sign I follow us at ranger
station and relay station two so I think
actually I hit both of those already so
maybe I'm gonna go toward relay station
four and six as well okay I'm coming up
on another sign yeah what makes sense
though because there was three relays so
yeah I guess I hit two things I think
I'm going for a relay station four okay
I'll keep an eye out for relay station
six they're both kind of pointing in the
same directions so I'm just kind of
following the Sun yeah my sign in there
point the same direction - Thank You
bear whoa it's got a lunge attack that's
not cool
my seagull friend left because I try to
murder on I've got the actual maniac
song stuck in my head I can't stop you
guys may not like it but this is what
peak whoever the band is that saying
that you're like oh Stone Age sounds
like is
and out on that state effect that one
I'm that's right all right so I've had a
sign that four and six split off I'm
going for four which is to the right of
design that I found okay so I'll go for
six I have a feeling that I'm like right
behind you who you probably are oh I see
it oh my god this is scary as hell how
do you the parkour use for the punk or
not it's not really a parkour it should
kind of like a fall are you it like the
drawbridge mark yeah I'm at the
drawbridge my advice would be don't do
that alright six it is alright okay you
up through a mountain pass like you went
up along when you might wonder if you
have to go to six first and then maybe
god I'm so wealthy with things good I
see it watching bear in the distance
these things some of these were
organized and someone waltzed in here
and just absolutely diarrhea all over
marks hard work I mean did Wade
specifically screw it up the
organization is for dweebs did you keep
going the mayor's can lunge don't have
you knew that first can you're like I
know that problem you yeah they kind of
like dive-bombed out uh out of the abyss
Wow I don't know if I'm going right I'm
just minding your own business then from
from the fog this here I found a cave
there's probably no bears in their
maturity to get through the cave oh I
have a machete I made a machete with you
thanks what go towards the other place
their shovels shovel bowls here plop my
shove shove them shove it oh [ __ ] here
it is
dude dude dude dude are you doing it
dude Bob I'm doing it I'm doing it for
you doing it did
food yeah I'm doing it for you save it
for me you freaking monster
there's nothing to encourage you not to
[ __ ] up it's me chasing your ass yeah
pretty much actually you do not know
it's very scary I don't I haven't seen
the clip Oh Bruns wrench okay one of
three relay stations active what does
that mean did you see that Bruns wrench
and choose not to grab it yeah I left
something for you man
ice flipped a switch okay we got two
notes
okay this relay station is active so we
need to get number four but how one of
three active is the other one I did yeah
so we just need to figure out a way to
get to four there's got to be a way to
jump that guy how'd you get up there
there's a way to parkour up the back
what OH
is there anything up there it was a
crate I got a full inventory from it
alright cool so about that wrench what
do we do with the wrench I even take it
back to the ranger station but we're
still missing one more tool that I'm
imagining is it the other relay place
okay so there's gotta be a way probably
here like somewhere connecting here as a
way to get to the other one that's what
I'm do we have a fruit compost recipe it
or is that new new fruit compote or
compost compost what does it say Wade
because fruit compost is not something
that you eat comm pod this is kompot
come you're the most uncivilized man
fruit comp I come pot I don't know the
cub pod
ah it's the fruit pod yes I have to open
inventory [ __ ] nope this island is
beautiful this is not the way let me
figure out the bridge no oh we're dumb
way back they weren't no I'm going back
down because I realized how to do it and
I I'm not gonna say it until I do it in
case something wrong I might be really
really dumb can I go with you there are
you still the case no I'm I passed the
cave I'm coming back to the sign that
splits up I'll wait for you you freak of
nature there you are I see you jigglin
Jesus Christ are things called Bruno's
acts and things saw definitely pre are
you Bruno's wrench absolutely on Bruno
no all right hold on Bob the outrage can
hold the first just a second you're
about to do I know right like that's
pretty smart boards this has got to be
it right I can't pull it back but it's
got to be something like this was a big
brain oh man I wonder how many people
got stuck on that
we're almost done Bob we're almost done
oh yeah many things don't worry about it
all right uh when you go upstairs
I got another note yeah that is Bruno's
Bruno's hammer grunt why would it be
Bruns oh you know common name Branagh
okay we got a pipe we got PI there's
nothing up here all right but the real
ace ace o two seven five six we got
pound two seven five six or more
coordinates down to 75 oh that is a
coordinate pound two seven five six okay
all right head your head to the ranger
station I'll I'll give this place a
once-over yes you said five six
caravan island caravan why is it crossed
out in the journal it's crossed out I
don't know I've never done deep island
this is all new [ __ ] for me we just
found little islands and try to get some
goats weird two seven five six though
that's pretty good all right Bob looks
like it's clear here way do you need
some more water or something before you
go I should have enough take some
watermelon just in case take those thank
you yes are you good to go on the place
yourself yeah that's fine okay Bob are
you near the beach are you about to
circle back I think I'm almost
background all right I'll come back help
with the ship and whatnot and Wade you
finish the
soft strong you do us proud okay you do
us proud
wait where's the beach I'm scared I
don't know where you are right god I see
you in the distance wait with my [ __ ]
ankles I'm going to stab it in the bone
I got right up the butthole right in the
bottle boy man this thing's just a
harvester yeah I'll take it back to the
boat you go ahead uh here take this then
just in case I need space alright see
around buddy how how do I get to the
boat um it should be to the left once
you see the next signpost it should be
the left to go down to the beach from
there okay I trust you thanks babe I
trust you oh I see the boat gets what
it's right down there
yeah Farquhar my way down we'll just go
straight down the mountain nothing can
possibly go wrong I'll catch you don't
worry
literally careening over the sides as we
speak alright baby baby no who did dump
everything yeah but he came through
you're nicely organized chest and was
just like listen not to distract but
also this is a secret achievement note
somebody read that while I try to make
my way back I'm not reading it mark you
have the voice that's like buttery
flowers on a baby bottom read it you was
a voice he's right
oh this is not in the game yet oh
alright we just see a bunch of time
doing a thing that's not at all no no
the next parts not in the game
apparently Caravan Island the thing we
just got coordinates for is apparently
not a thing yet okay I'll read this real
quick I'll give you the Cliff Notes
version of it first entry lefty the
auxiliary boat I'm sorry Bruno they're
all alone out there second entry Albert
to him is to contact someone they
sounded foreign but they might have been
the Navy ask them about you they didn't
seem like they were receiving number six
went underwater left a message in case
can't be so bad this is Bruno signing
off Albert day I found your wrench out
by the clearing did you leave it there
is this some kind of game I know it's
been rough on you being stuck out here
but I think
Cruel please if you're here I just want
to talk fourth entry number three is
gone but I'm fine I'm not angry Alberta
you keep saying I'm angry I'm not angry
just tired you keep hiding from me
birthday I know you're here someplace no
matter the water will drive you out
Henry says I shouldn't say that but it
makes me feel like a right old bastard
but you left me here and I'm sorry but
it's just the way things are
okay fifth entry how did Vonnegut put it
something about not enough people you
keep telling me I need to go Albert a
but you're just not enough people eh I
don't even know if you're anyone else
you remember how the guys used to pull
our legs back at Central one guy two
paychecks ha ha ha but maybe they were
onto something Albert a six entry
Miranda made a scene the other day said
Henry is getting too clingy
Errol likes to push her buttons but I
know how she can get she hasn't done
anything but Jesus that woman scares me
Bobby says we should have talked with
her about it but he won't do it so what
the hell is good is he Albert day I
found your harness but it looks in bad
shape I worry about you um oh there's
more okay Errol's gone Miranda likes to
act like nothing happened but we know
better we all know better except Bobby's
gone awful quiet
Henry won't talk about it but Bobby I
can tell he's worried the trip will
think I'm too quick to point fingers
that he'll turn up but they don't know
Errol
he's helpless without anyone holding my
hand my hair's getting thinner
sometimes I mumble back what I just said
just to hear me say Henry's right I'm
turning into my father
a thin tree I'll birthday I don't think
anyone's coming I think
Errol is gone for good - Henry says I
oughta make a choice the others they
won't make it here it would be cruel to
leave them now that Bobby is useless
they don't know this place they were
just born in it I'll leave as soon as
they've all gone Henry keeps saying I'm
doing the right thing but with the water
it's getting higher in the generators
mostly gone - my father called me the
other day asked me if I'm coming home
but he's been gone for years and I don't
know if I'm not just desperate 9th entry
Henry - and I took the auxilary boat I'm
sorry Albert I am here all alone out
here Bruno alright well that's a whole
saga oh god wait back eyes even faster
wait
you really shouldn't have touched Bruno
stuff man man
Bruno really did a number on you man the
question is what was in the ranger
station the last note I got it was I so
I had to put tools on the little tool
shelf or whatever and then it dropped
onto the floor and just revealed a note
so god I guess was the big secret the
big thing was those coordinates that I
guess lead nowhere yet yes so the
question is all these extra things that
they got us like the biofuel refiner the
bio fuel tank the pipe what is it for
like a battery engine fuel source right
probably Oh what if we put the honey in
the research thing did we try that I did
not yeah see if we can make a honey jar
yeah because unfortunately seems like we
may be approaching the end of the
content that's here but there's a lot of
like crafting stuff left to discover
yeah we haven't encountered any of the
animal islands and we haven't done the
puffer fish stuff we should chug along
and try and find some more islands I
think so where did the honey go anybody
get the honey oh I might have moved it
up to the food okay there we go and then
honey okay we researched honey
Oh bee jar hope you catch the bees and
the bee jar ah-6 honey Jesus Christ okay
all right okay all right are we leaving
this island or now and let me come how
to get bees sweep sweep net the of
course useful for catching bugs
all right fine then take this goo and
make a sweep net and then you go run off
and get us some bees baby I'll take a
walk into the distance life it just
makes you want to sing yeah
and a little Home Slice that your
skillet baby baby I will never call you
skillet baby why my lychee I don't know
and try to be just born this way did you
say born this way I did isn't it awesome
I want to die I thought maybe you guys
would appreciate that one my leg itches
all right back on a mission what do I do
with the bees once they're in the net
hey I don't know if you remember that
well I remember now give it's a tiny bit
of Health it's very small but they do
it's just yeah but I guess soup would be
a smarter way right I mean we just need
clay for bowls which I think we have a
pretty good stash of clay anyway yeah
let me go find the clay so once the bees
are in the net I don't put them in
anything right I just have bees just get
the bee I don't know man just get a bead
I got four plus four B jar and I got
stung love it get the bees we do not
have enough clay oh really
we have play bricks we we don't have
clay Oh Frick well the potatoes are
still valuable for the soup we just need
a hidden island where we can grab up
some clay yeah we do Wade you got those
bees I've got four
the other ones are being [ __ ] are
too high what you're tall what do we do
with bear heads
can I wear three bear heads probably no
I cannot wear three bear heads go back
home Bears be with your people in the
sea maybe we camouflage with the bear
heads they never would have known you're
wearing a bear head this is true they
wanted to kill me just as much if not
more they really did how many bees do we
need I'll get as many as you can they
just they won't land make Oh hardly
distracted by your greatness come and
give me once and twice and thrice
talking about you mad be human only to
lure the bees you mad human why would
they want honey they make honey use a
vacuum what I'm sorry who recommended
them
Oh a shed someone who doesn't want
speaking privileges no more I have 19 B
jars is that enough
yeah yeah that seems good what do you
mean using the bees doors we're gonna
make beehives in that way we can make
honey on the go okay is it like a thing
we're like once we have one started we
can know if the bees [ __ ] I asking me
that is that what you're asking me I
don't know we didn't bee to like yeah
man you know dude I don't know I can
hope and I wish but I don't know I
caught a lot of bees I hope there was a
queen in there somewhere does it kind of
like yeah you know I don't know I'm
thinking about it just as much as you
are but I don't know everyone needs to
calm down and stop talking about bees
banging I'm pretty sure that's not how
it works
whoa who put a lantern up by the up by
the cooking stuff look at that that's
been there for since I was in the
cooking it's a good idea I'm glad that
that happened
thanks man thank you why are these mango
trees not growing at all are they done
maybe I made a mistake you did job and
now I'm back we made a mistake that we
waited for you is that what you're
saying probably because now you look at
my twitchy self again are you really
alright thank you wait your job services
is something sighs okay Bob give him a
medal I don't know wait I have something
to present you with right here then you
for your outstanding service to our raft
and ordination I give you wait stop the
ceremony
[Music]